[Music]
alone a very warm welcome to quadriga
coming to you from the heart of Berlin
at this time around we're looking at
france's crucial presidential election
where the campaign shifted into top gear
this past week with both of the leading
candidates delivering fiery addresses to
their supporters marine lepen of the far
right from nacional hopes to capitalize
on the anti-establishment mood that led
to the brexit vote in the UK and the
election of Donald Trump in the US
meanwhile centrist independent emmanuel
macron is also running as a candidate
outside the political mainstream and the
man who was until very recently a
serious contender the conservative
francois fian is struggling after
becoming mired in a corruption scandal
so our topic this week on quadriga
French election campaign battle of the
outsiders and it is too good discuss it
all i'm joined here in the studio by
three seasoned analysts and observers
beginning with Tony Paterson Germany
correspondent for the independent
newspaper who says France is being torn
apart by the same forces that drove
Britain's Briggs it it's time for the
moderate candidates he says in the
presidential election to wake up and
fight before it's too late also with us
today's burka burka from German public
radio deutschland radio who's a former
friends correspondent Burkhart believes
that the French are fed up with corrupt
politicians but not necessarily with
Europe that's an interesting thought and
a very warm welcome to to pasco Booga
french writer based here in Berlin who
says affairs and hidden accounts the
established parties have discredited
themselves the resulting chaos is a huge
opportunity for marine lepen well Pascoe
I'd like to begin with you the election
campaigners are got into full swing this
past week map out forest why this is so
very important for France and for the
people of France well the problem is
that the election campaign has got very
fiery because of scandals but not
because of the programs over the
political parties nobody talks about
them anymore the new star of French
politique Emmanuel Marco has unveiled
his program yet that's going to be done
at the weekend the main candidate who
everybody thought two weeks ago would
probably win the election Francois fume
is embroidered in a scandal he's a very
moral man he's a very he's always been
criticizing French politics for being
corrupt and now he is as well attached
by a scandal and marine lepen is going
to profit from that because I think the
French are so fed up with you know this
hardly any French political who hasn't
been embroiled in a scandal it's amazing
when you compare to Germany where hardly
any political person here is embroiled
in a scandal so the French are very very
fed up and it might be I mean I'm sure
that a lot of people would now say well
we vote marine lepen although she's also
embroiled in scandals but it's very
strange for Francois Villon we noticed
in the last past days that a lot of his
supporters of the conservative voters
are hesitant now and have a lot of
questions to him and marine lepen has
several scandal scandal with the FISC
she's also employed people with the
money of the european parliament for her
own offices and with her the four
national voters don't seem to be to be
resentful about that they will still
vote for her broke a burka Tony Paterson
have you got anything to add to that
panoramic here accessibility of why this
is such an important election for
LaGrone accion well I think it's it's
symptomatic of what's happening all over
europe really i mean that you've got a
new kind of orbit not hitherto
unrecognized of section of society which
has suddenly started to speak out in
this section of society of the people
who feel that they've been left behind
they're the result these are people who
voted communists in France beforehand
who are now voting for the pen and
you've got vast areas where society
isn't working immigration has got
possibly out of control all these white
french people are left without jobs they
feel that immigrants moving into their
areas and this is all absolute fodder
for the four national
as it was in interim brexit in Britain
and I think this is this is something
that's happening all over Europe and as
a question of with which way our
politicians dealing with it and in
France they found marine lepen my
question is okay it looks like she's
going to do very well in the first round
but the second round is the one that
counts and how she gonna do there we've
been here before haven't we yeah but I'd
reckon I mean if it really comes down to
showdown between marine lepen and any
other candidate and i really say any
because you don't know if McConnell
really might make it into the second
round of the presidential election the
other candidate will still win that's my
that's my bet I mean because I think the
Republican sense as they call it in
French will kick in in that moment and
the electoral system in France is so
that it prohibits actually a good way
for the phone as to not if you consider
the phone asuna is that about twenty
eight percent of the popular vote was
the strongest party at the european
election and all he's got two seats at
the National Assembly out of 577 so a
large proportion of the population does
not feel represented parliamentary and
this causes for a lot of garage in the
in the population you got to see there's
a deep divide between the phosphor
phoned the deep country rural France and
the cities which does not reflect the
real sentiment in the country now there
are two guys maybe McCall why would I
bet on him because he says Europe can be
the answer is the only pure European
candidate who wants to pick up those
ideas of exclusion though he's himself
from the establishment who says we must
work together in Europe to find his
solution okay emmanuel macron we've
heard it already we've heard it in the
debate is the current favorite to emerge
as the winner from this vote he's just
about young enough to be called the new
kid on the block I think it's fair to
say let's find out a little bit more
about it before we continue the
discussion
the rising star of French politics 39
year-old emmanuel macron founder of a
new political party called on marsh or
forward he says that for France the best
is yet to come look at the support of
course you can sum up the essence of our
vision for France and three words
liberty equality and fraternity McCraw
has promised to reform the labor market
improve the education system and promote
globalization his supporters see him as
an anti-establishment candidate despite
the fact that he's a former cabinet
minister and has worked as an investment
banker said McCraw is considered a
centrist by many he's launched scathing
attacks against the right-wing populists
candidate marine lepen and is a staunch
supporter of the european union
but kemah prob deliver on the promises
that he's made a ska luta McCarl insider
or outsider I think he's bows and I
think we are focusing on him now it's
very difficult to make a prognosis I
agree with you the electoral system
normally should block marine lepen and
we had that already in 2002 when in the
in the second round of the election it
was sheer luck against the Roma will
append the father of muffin and
everybody went on the street first and
then everybody whether you were
socialists communists green or
conservative you all voted there was a
full public our Republican front and you
voted for the other candidate against
Jean machi Lupin now is that going to
happen this time I would think so I mean
if it's a duel between Macomb and Mahela
pen I would think that most people it
doesn't matter which political color
will vote for my conscience to block the
way to marine lepen but McCoy's very
young very young he has been part of the
government and he promoted some quite
unpopular laws about work the crew also
say yeah which were very very very
unpopular were thousands of people on
the streets for week and weeks and weeks
and that people have been forgotten has
he got enough you know played bleed a
political basis people supporting him
whatever the questions I mean has he got
a political party that is really backing
of he's also compared to gentlemen so
often compared all yeah often I think
it's fair enough to say to Barack Obama
or to Justine through a door in Canada
is that a fair comparison as I help why
do we know well as they have that much
substance an end point any comparison is
bad but i think it's it's not not very
very helpful to look at that but you
gotta consider he's got already a
hundred sixty thousand followers at
least that's what he pretends in france
the party system a part of the Communist
Party and the Socialist Party is very
volatile I mean you can found a new
party in weeks so I don't think this
would really be the problem if you
select the president he will make out of
his movement in march on max political
party just like the UMP was created
before the Republicans later always to
find majorities for the president so I
don't think this would be the major
problem the problem is that he comes
from the establishment it pretends to be
an anti-establishment candidate but any
of the candidate men are shown from the
left I'm all from the Socialist Party a
marine lepen they all say they're
against the system even fiancé's he's
against the system and they mean
different things vo means the
bureaucracy and the marine lepen means
the establishment of the traditional
parties socialists and Republicans or
even pay before so it's it's it's a
slogan to be against the system huh in
France I think another thing is but in
the pens favor is that the fact that the
party's gone through undergone a
makeover since they got rid of jean
marie lepen they've got rid of all the
sort of anti-semitic stuff that they had
with him at least ostensibly they've had
this new the person behind the throne
filippo who has been the the mastermind
behind this new face of the fauna so now
which has made the party perhaps appeal
a bit more to her to a wider spectrum of
voters and then I think possibly that
the the fact that the party is really
sort of moving really addressing the
problems of this so-called underclass
that's developed across Europe ting in a
lot of societies that that's that's
helping it I think that's sort of the
other factories I think that what may
play against r is the fact that the
socialist candidate how mall may take
away some of the vote that's going that
may go to Levin and we just pick up on
another point of book I've made because
I'd like to hear what you have to say
coming from your perspective as the as
the Germany correspondence of the
independent newspaper how important is
it that emmanuel macron is forthrightly
as vigorously pro-european well I think
he's got to take on the ante Europe
rhetoric that nap n
delivering and face up against it and
this is one thing that hasn't happened
in Britain that the Labour Party has
done so badly because it has had really
no stance on this issue so I think it's
important that he does take a stand on
Europe and address the positive things
about de you ask are you are nodding yes
absolutely and he's probably going to be
yeah he's going to be the only one and
there's a big front of the population
who is still very poor European and more
pro-european now that Donald Trump has
been elected in America a lot of people
see now that Europe is very important
that it's our chance to resist what
seemed what is quite frightening so I
think he's young he's a could be a very
moment an important moment in European
politics were people in Europe they see
the phret perhaps or the challenges
posed by President Trump they see the
challenges posed by Vladamir Putin on
the other side and they think well maybe
the EU much-maligned in recent times is
my best bet here well well I would hope
so and hope to see what it's of a bigger
version of what happened in Austria that
there's a sort of rejection basically it
is this purpose of crazy populism that's
taking over with a lot of basically
untruths in in in their campaigns that
the voice of reason will prevail I mean
I think that's what most people are
hoping for or these French relations
take place at the cross role of European
history because I mean just imagine
marine lepen being elected and it's the
end of Europe so it's really defining
Europe's fate and if you have a guy like
McCombs the only but the only real
candidate of those presenting themselves
at this election that's pro-european
because what is francois pinault he's
for Europe of the nation's he's not for
deeper Europe so he's the only one and
he says I mean with a bright student
Trump as a menace as a bad example I
think he he could try to convince his
people but he's got to present his
program that's the size of the latest
poll in French television says the
decisive point is the program of the
candidate than his credibility and that
is not corrupt
okay he just talks about the threat
posed by marine lepen for this
crossroads in European history is you're
describing it let's catch up with marine
lepen I mean she too likes present
herself as an outsider despite the fact
that she comes from what is effectively
I suppose you could call a political
dynasty let's have a fur let's get some
images she believes that France is on
the verge of collapse and only she can
save it
actually did assault the parties on the
right and on the left care only about
money but I am the candidate of the
people of France gonna post it back but
the pen also belongs to the political
establishment she's been a European MP
since 2004 and she's been accused of
misusing about three hundred thousand
euros in EU funds to help her political
party Levin has vowed to put France
first renegotiate the country's status
with the EU protect France against
globalization restrict immigration and
crack down on islamist radicals recent
polls indicate that lapan will likely
win the first round of voting but not
the second but didn't the polls also
failed to predict Donald Trump's victory
Tony partisan marine lepen dead as you
know does the fact that the the
possibility that she could win this vote
mean that we are at a crossroads of
European history absolutely i mean
haven't quite got there yet again we're
moving there fast i mean i think what we
have to bear in mind is sort of
something which hasn't really been
addressed in a lot of these certainly
not in the brexit thing and certainly I
don't think that much in the French
presidential campaign is what Helmut
Kohl was going on about basically Europe
is something which is guaranteed peace
for quite some time and Helmut Kohl was
sort of laughed at and sneered at a bit
for sort of saying that when he was in
power in Germany but I think if the
light bulb can go on in sort of people's
heads that Europe is something that is
actually worth hanging on to because it
is a question of values and it's not
actually ultimately responsible for
economic decline everywhere a lot of the
a lot of this these problems that
individual European countries are facing
a self-made or homemade problems if some
something can come across in in that
direction then that would be positive I
think hmm fascinating thoughts Pascal
I'm still I'd like to just go back to
marine depend for a minute because I
mean with each of you more or less
hazdeb been doing the maths and being
saying that she can't really win this
she can't go all the way
is that really the case at the top of
the show we had to quote from you where
you said this is a huge opportunity for
marine lepen a real opportunity well as
I said before I think I think normally
it's not possible but we've been to so
many surprises you know going to bed in
the evening thinking okay everything is
fine getting up the next morning and it
breaks it but at the moment for my
chrome we have on the second round of
voting macro on 60 something percent
yeah yeah yes I'm huge mark is the run
to my surprise there's another scenario
which you could picture I mean just
imagine the two candidates from the left
Milan Sean and ammo would unite and say
we only present one candidate yeah and
the other becomes Prime Minister
whenever the other one gets elected if
they present one candidate then the left
candidate will win I will come into the
second round and if you have a more or
Milan Shaw against blue pen then I
wouldn't bet yeah and I wouldn't bet
that marine lepen might not get through
so there's scenarios where she could
really come to the presidency but then
again you have the National Assembly
election and the majority voting system
and friends will prohibit that the
harness and I'll go get the majority of
parliamentary seats so there is always a
block but I mean this would be a
scenarios as I just mentioned the left
would unite which I don't see but if
they unite then then there might be a
part of trouble ahead and the important
thing is which party is going to at last
at la dress the the fears and and the
problems of the the little French people
live of this micros not doing that is he
not addressing those he's too much a man
of business and why we don't know he's
going to unveil his program soon but
he's a he's going to not as strongly as
she all but he's going to introduce
reforms like Germany did 15 years ago
and these new forms are going to be very
painful and the French don't want to
leave their privilege you know in France
people are are in uproar because the age
of retirement could be pushed from 60 62
265 they find it impossible they don't
want to work 39 hours a week they don't
want I mean they all these privileges a
country where the social system the
welfare system is still very general
and and to cut that the candidate who
wants to cut that is going to be
punished it's going to be very difficult
sorry Patterson is there any kind of a
lot of people when I've been told people
this week about the the debate that
we're gonna be having today and a lot of
people said to me oh that's interesting
because there's a there's a comparison
to be made between McCraw and the
success he's having in France the surge
he's on with with Martin Schulz here in
Germany the former president of the
european parliament who's giving Angela
Merkel suddenly it appears a run for her
money yeah both pro-european yes broke
both pro-european but they've got
actually I think spell that out in much
much bigger terms I mean we know that in
Germany at Martin Schulz his former
President of the European Parliament is
in his pro-europe but he hasn't actually
spelled it out for Germany what it what
it means and nor has McCaw he's got to
really unveil his program and say what
does Europe mean to the electorate to
turn electorate that is basically very
skeptical and think he will you know
just just like it as it was him in
Britain and they think that Brussels is
an elite that is controlling their lives
and the the appeal of leaving a frecks
it France leaving leaving you is there
it's not some sort of ghost phenomen and
it's actually present people feel that
nevertheless mcconnell has a broad idea
because he wants to renegotiate europe
on on and on a different contract and he
wants to ask the people of europe and
the different countries take their
opinion and then renegotiate Europe and
to give it a new direction that's what
he said that listen some of the meetings
I attended and that is also the
principle he is applying for his own
program he's sending out all his little
helpers to go to the different houses to
the people ask them what do you want
where are your necessities why do you
feel excluded and from there he pretends
to write his program we're gonna be very
curious which is going to be the program
as Pascal Luke said and the program will
be decisive he is aiming for the middle
he wants to he wants to break with its
left and right you'll either at the
right or you at the left he wants to
break with that whereas the left-handed
at marine lepen are gonna dispute I mean
the frustrated people the old working
class that are out of jobs that are
afraid of losing with a globalization
yes he has another stylist well I saw
him in Berlin a few weeks ago I mean
he's young he's enthusiastic he hasn't
got this rhetoric that a lot of french
politician a little bit older half of
speaking of love halls in a sort of path
of pathos he's simple he's clear and I
think that appeals to people and he's
the only one until now who hasn't get an
affair I mean there's ground yeah which
you have to add value in itself clearly
everyone marine lepen let's cut this
down I listen and watch it what do you
make of this you know the the comparison
between shorts and back roll is that are
useful are they providing a new template
for perhaps this it's very difficult
they are so different I mean they are
very pure pro-european bows and they're
both these kind of puppets which have
come out of at the last yeah well I mean
puppets it sir that's a bad word I burnt
appear to be speaking more directly to
the people yeah and they both stayed you
have this surprise effect I mean you
know they are the new candidates they
are they were on their unexpected thrown
in the middle of the political arena
that's that's a huge asset and yeah and
they have both in a very different way I
mean you know I mean they are very very
different shoes the German hasn't got
his a levels you know he was an
alcoholic he wanted to be a football
player and then he became a he had a
bookshop I mean he's with yourself man
made in the German sense which I find
very sympathetic well Marco is very
different you know he comes from the
elite of the French she's been brought
up in this system of he speaks a very
polished French so you can't really you
can I think that Schultz has more has
more chances to appeal to the normal
ordinary German than Mac home to the
ordinary Frenchman because Michael
definitely belongs to the establishment
but let think beyond I mean if you have
a Chancellor Schultz and and President
McCall that's really move forward yeah
that's definite
that's an interesting tandem with my
final question we're running out of time
with which option sends a shiver a
greater shiver down your spine marine
lepen winning this presidential election
in France with all her divisive
tendencies in her anti-european stance
or a man who's never been elected to
public office before all the
unpredictability of emmanuel macron well
for me marine lepen is a no-go
absolutely no go because her program is
not realizable she wants to get out of
the euro she wants to get out of the
NATO she wants to fix it that's a no-go
and she's promising things she won't be
able to keep so my call definitely is
something like the grand coalition in
Germany that's his policy a pro-european
I mean that that for me that would be if
I was French that would be the man I
would vote for in that constellation
marine lepen or him okay me too without
any shadow of a doubt and what we are
talking about moline loop n being
anti-european but there's much worse
she's polished or discourse very much
compared to her father but they are
anti-semites you know this is the exam
of phobia racism keeping France for
itself I mean the ideology behind her is
very dangerous and very unpleasant to
say the least so Mike home without the
shadow of a doubt we have two votes for
micron at the moment Tony well I think
obviously I would agree with both of you
and I think another element comes in
here that if that if she gets in then
the franco-german alliance which is the
motivating power the motor behind Europe
that's broken seriously broken if she
gets him and that is going to be mean
that Europe is going to start to unravel
and that is something very dangerous
prospect envy okay thank you all for
your insights on the French election
campaign outside of versus an outsider
come back next week if you've enjoyed
the show as much as I have bye-bye and
choose
[Music]